Use case diagrams will have two major icons. One are some stick figures and
these denote external actors. Typically, these are system users, but they
may also stand for other systems or external devices. In the use case diagram,
ovals are use cases. That is, this is, a use case diagram is not a system story.
It's a description of the set of system stories. Lines in the diagram
without annotations indicate participation. That means that the actor at one end
is involved in the use case oval at the other end. There're two
annotations available in use case diagrams. One is the extends annotation and
the other is the uses annotation. Extends mean that you have one story and
you'd like to extend it by some other contingencies, essentially getting two for
the price of one. The uses stereotype is like a subroutine or, or function call.
That is, a common piece of behavior that might used by several other use cases.